i i don't think i would want to do
something that high profile because if
you screw up it would be a big deal
oh look at you you're afraid to fail now
oh you make it big you sell your company
and now
and now you're like i i gotta i gotta
watch my step what's going on
where's the guy with the pirate ship
tattooed on his thigh what would that
guy do
yeah i feel like i can rule the world
sean's new studio are you in a garage is
that what that is i am in my garage
we uh we upgraded we improvised
so we did this crazy thing where we had
talked about on the podcast we were like
[__] we need to like upgrade our setup
i think mostly was you just telling me
to get a haircut which is fair um and
wear a shirt
wear a shirt and uh i took that as i
need a whole new studio
uh so so basically these guys who are
um from chicago they're like 23 year old
guys who love the podcast they were like
they heard that
and this is like their forte they do
like camera audio
they have their own podcast they have
their own youtube channels they're
basically
what i realized was i went and watched
their youtube channel and this youtube
channel has like this guy
henry his youtube channel has like i
don't know five hundred and
subscribers so it's not like some big
youtube channel but if you watch it
it's the same level of quality of like
video audio
and editing as like casey neistat's
channel and i showed this to our friend
sully and i go
i go check these guys out like look at
look at their channel these are the guys
coming this weekend to make my studio
and he goes he goes i remember when i
was
kind of like 21 22 we were coming up and
what
the kind of 30 and 40 year olds used to
say was oh man you guys have this huge
advantage because you're like you're
you're like digital natives that's what
they were calling us like we grew up
with a computer
and the internet like i think we got the
internet and computers when we were like
in sixth grade i don't know about you
it's probably around the same fifth
sixth grade something like that
and so you know first for our parents
they were getting a computer when they
were 35 or 40. so it's just like you
know
you didn't have that you didn't have it
to grow up on and so he goes
these guys this is the next the next
wave they're video native
basically they grew up with a camera in
their hand and they just like constantly
shoot videos they know how to edit it
they're not afraid to be on camera
and like it's such a super power and i
think it was so true
what he was saying you said one thought
line that i think is the real superpower
which is
um being on camera so for you and i
be we're kind of like media people so
we're maybe a little bit more used to it
than the average joe
but even i am still very uncomfortable
just talking to a camera
and like looking at it young people are
not when i was at the airport i saw
12 year old kids with like the phone on
the ground with a pop socket right and
they were like filling and i could see
that they were doing tick tock dances
and it was like that's like unheard of
for me because i'm like oh my god you're
gonna do that at the airport with people
watching
right right yeah the upside is they all
look cool
they know how to dance and they know how
to edit videos the downside is
like you know they're like riddled with
anxiety and stuff like that so you know
it's not all it's not all good but but
and they're not having sex which is a
topic we're going to talk about we're
going to talk about that
um but the other thing i was going to
say is let me ask you this
when you get us you're on snapchat right
you have snapchat
uh i have no i have an account all right
so all right bray you
are you you got to chime in here i bet
you how old are you
27 all right so you're more like us than
i like the people i'm talking about that
are kind of like i'm not going to say
gen z yeah but john i think i think
those couple
he is he's a lot hipper
he's a lot hipper than we are all right
he's a little bit more into it
okay so so basically uh when you have
snapchat right
so someone sends you a snap right they
send you a picture of something they're
doing something looking at
and you need to reply tell me do you
just type the reply
like in the text version or do you send
back a photo
that's so weird yeah see that's crazy to
me uh that is wild to me i'm like
you say something i comment like it's
[__] like it's facebook right i just
write like
oh looks fun cool that's great you know
like i'm like a
90 year old you're talking about young
people another interesting thing to do
is when you ask a young person or did
you show me this when you ask a younger
person
what what do you do when someone calls
if they put their hand
for the people listening i have my hand
like i'm
waving high like high five and they put
their hand like a high five to the ear
versus they put their pinky and thumb
out like this
well or or if you say um hey do like a
gesture to take a picture
so if i said to you hey sam take a
picture yeah you're gonna do this that's
an old
camera yeah there's not a camera right
so so what they do is they
they hold up their their hand like this
with their thumb like you're holding an
iphone right
we're like out here with a polaroid
trying to
trying to demonstrate what a picture is
anyway so um i don't even know why i'm
talking about that but basically
these guys are you know i would say
younger people are video native and i
think that's going to be a
huge huge win for them because people
like us are like self-conscious and like
just don't know how to use the tools
right
i want to bring up a topic that's both
related to this and something else so
at sean's old office at monkey inferno
the guy who owns it michael
burch awesome it looked like it was out
of a magazine but he had one or two
things that
really stuck out and one of them was
this macintosh computer it was a max
mac two is that what's called two apple
ii so
i'm gonna look that up so the reason i'm
bringing this up
is i am building my studio to look good
like yours
um and i was looking thinking of like
designs and
interesting stuff to put in the back and
i also this whole nft has got me
uh interested in art and like you know
just beautiful
yeah just like valuable or not valuable
beautiful interesting cool stuff i've
always liked stuff
uh just like junk right uh that's what i
used to like
uh but now i'm gonna try to get some
nicer [__] anyway i was
looking around how much do you think uh
so is an apple ii is that apple ii the
same as a mac as a
macintosh too uh i don't know
well wow how much you think an apple ii
that still works costs i don't know a
couple thousand i'd say maybe
somewhere between two and five it would
be my guess two and five thousand you
can get
one that's in pretty good condition for
like five hundred dollars
you can get one you can get a mac
macintosh two which
i don't know the difference between the
apple ii and the macintosh ii you can
get a macintosh too
that is still in the box for like a
grand
and do you remember the commercials when
we were younger we were in our teens we
were probably in eighth grade or ninth
grade
where it was like a colored mac
so it was like a blue it was called the
imac i think right yep
you can get those for like 300
now strictly speaking like from like a
collectible like
just it's interesting it's um it's cool
to look at that's
incredibly cheap for a machine
i tell you what every single person who
came to our office was like
oh this is awesome now granted it's tech
nerds coming to the office but
they were like wowed by this thing and
there was like expensive art all up on
the walls nobody cared about any of that
people saw this old thing and then we
would boot it up and they would turn on
and they were like
amazed by it so it definitely every
single person
commented on it i think these types of
like old computers these
vintage computers i think these are
going to get really popular and the
reason i think that is i was looking up
how much uh so for a gift i thought
about buying people
a an ipod that wasn't connected to the
internet did i tell you this
no um so i was gonna buy people uh like
our investors i was gonna buy them like
a small thank you i was like maybe if i
spent 200
ahead let's see if i can go and buy a
bunch of if i can buy like 20
uh ipods that aren't connected to the
internet and my plan was ruined because
i'm like oh wait
you have to have uh itunes itunes and
that doesn't even exist so like this is
pretty much meaningless
but these old ipods by the way itunes
exists
well but i mean like you who no one buys
it can you even buy mp3s anymore from it
i don't think so yeah you have to like
have your own music
yeah like that no one does that anymore
you we all stream and like these things
didn't even have internet i wanted it so
you could like download it and then it
would only work if you were attached to
wi-fi
but anyway uh old ipods
like old old ones first generation ones
are expensive like five six hundred
dollars
and so anyway i think that both it would
be cool to have this stuff
on your dude if an old ipod is five six
hundred dollars and
apple ii in the box or mac 2 in the box
is also 500
yeah i i definitely know which one i
think has more
more like long-term value here uh those
those
those things are collectibles i think
you're you're spot on i would scoop up
five to ten of those right now and just
hold them yeah i'm
okay so look here's a vintage working in
one in good condition
uh macintosh two for 250 i'm looking at
it
on ebay right now here's a macintosh uh
in the box for 400 bucks
[Laughter]
it's pretty interesting right i think
this might become pretty popular these
old computers and i think that it's kind
of a cool idea
yeah i like that a lot um those are good
and i i actually will
go after this on ebay and try to scoop
up at least at least two of those
just to hold and see what happens um all
right you want to get into
uh you have two updates and then we have
an idea two ideas
yeah okay so one update is on the
michael jordan thing so last episode we
talked about michael jordan's house has
been on sale for 10 years
it was a it's a 56 000 square foot house
and um it was originally listed for 30
million dollars now it's
been price cut price cut price get all
the way down to 13 million
and it's still not selling and this is
after the last dance it's after this
giant boom in like trading card
collectibles like the michael jordan
rookie card
is going for almost 2 million dollars
and his 56 000 square foot house
can't sell for 13. like something seems
off like a little tiny
three-inch piece of cardboard can sell
but not this so
uh and he's paying property taxes i
think some somebody said he's paid
about a million dollars in property tax
just while it's sat on the market
and so we threw this out there last time
we said hey look
why don't we either collect just me and
you or
we crowdfund uh why don't we buy mj's
house and like what could we do with it
and we got a bunch of good feedback so i
would say like there's a bunch of smart
people who immediately pointed out
that one of our ideas which was to turn
it into some kind of
museum the museum of mike um you know
the basketball museum
wouldn't work because you know the hoa
the neighbors would never permit you to
let
like tens of thousands of people come
into their neighborhood and go to this
museum every year right so that's what i
thought about
i mean i was thinking about i just
figured there's got to be a way around
something
exactly exactly when you start an idea
you don't think about all the
different like small reasons why it
might immediately fail you think you
know
what if this works and then you try to
find a way to make it work
um but the more interesting one in my
opinion was
always the simpler one which was you
don't have to turn it into a museum
you don't have to get permitting you
don't have to have guests coming in and
operations folks
you just treat it differently you don't
treat it like a house
you treat it like it's a monument it's a
piece of art and
there are paintings that sell for 85
million dollars
and so if for painting itself for 85
million dollars i think michael jordan's
house this relic of the greatest
basketball player of all time
is going to be worth something and so
the idea would be
you crowdfund it you get i don't know 5
000 people to each pitch in 2 grand
you buy the thing out for 10 million
bucks and uh you hold it as a piece of
art
and then you know what i there's a
couple of good suggestions i thought
came in through twitter so some of the
good suggestions were
you could list this on rally road where
people go
to buy like you know vintage cars or
rare first edition lord of the rings
book sets for thirty five thousand
dollars that you
you know 500 people each buy it a
fractional share of it
so that was one idea people liked and
the rally road guys said hey we're
interested let's talk
so i'm talking about they they howled at
you they did they replied to the tweet
and then rob the
i think he's the ceo i know his
co-founder uh he emailed me yesterday
and so we're gonna we're gonna chat and
see what is everyone cool reach out to
you bro they know they know
damn i didn't get anyone hollered at me
well are you
are your dms open on twitter my dms are
open yes
i've also talked to him before through
dms because i was just like rally is
[__] awesome so i had reached out to
him
actually and that's it saying hey riley
is awesome can i invest in this thing
so he knew i was a fan boy already um
but anyway so that was one interesting
thing
some people in the crypto world were
like dude let's turn this into an nft
bro
and uh so i talked to the the founder of
of nifty gateway
which is just exploding this this
marketplace is just exploding for nfts
right now so
i asked him hey would you like to dabble
and then the last thing was that some
people were like hey and what did they
say
uh he was like hey this is cool but he
was like you know we're just crushing so
hard on the digital stuff
i don't know if we want to get into this
physical thing uh because there were
some cool
ideas from from twitter some people were
like you know let's say you came in and
you bought a 50
000 chunk so you instead of the 2 000
entry you go for 50k that should get you
like
if you present your your certificate of
ownership if you show your app and you
show that you're
you own a piece of this thing um you
should be able to have like a
three-night stay once a year
with you and all your friends we're
gonna time share mj's house
exactly so so you're not fully doing an
airbnb you're treating it like it's art
but if you own a big enough share if
you're you know a super minority owner
of this thing then you can actually stay
one weekend a year and i thought that
was pretty dope
um so anyways there's some cool ideas
but then at the same time
i ain't got time to do this and neither
do you so uh
what's gonna happen from here you're
asking me i don't know i feel like
you're
kind of the leader on this one uh
nothing if i had
that nothing i here and here's why
when i did my deal every smart person i
talked to
what did you know what they said i bet
you can guess what they said no no what
did they say
do nothing for six months right so don't
invest it on your hands
yeah yeah don't invest and so many times
i've been
i've wanted to change and do something
and everyone has said the same thing and
i'm gonna try my hardest to stick to it
so that's one of the reasons why
although
that's probably a [__] excuse the
reality is it's kind of an
i don't think i would want to do
something that high profile because if
you screw up it would be a big deal
oh look at you you're afraid to fail now
oh you make it big you sell your company
and now
now you're like i i gotta watch my step
what's going on
i'm not afraid where's the guy with the
pirate ship tattooed on his thigh what
would that guy do
dude my first time buying like a
a real estate asset and doing something
like this would be like
i mean that would be national i mean i
guess yeah i'm being i'm okay i'm not
i'm not saying you buy it i'm saying
clearly the way to go here
is to crowdfund this thing because it's
just more fun that way
and you don't have to put out 10 million
dollars of risk capital how many emails
did you get
so somebody oh yeah that was the other
thing so somebody created a website uh
jonathan created a website i think it's
like by byjordanshouse.com or something
like that
and i think he said you know pretty
early on after the tweet he said he had
200 people
dropping their email and i think about
the same on twitter said
i'm in including a bunch of higher
profile people there's a bunch of people
who are a bunch of really
wealthy people founders of companies uh
owners of owners of businesses that were
like i'm in for 5k i'm in for 10k
type of thing now are they just talking
is this real i don't know we'll see
but i think it was cool i mean the the
little video that we had reached a
hundred thousand people i think
uh across a couple of different
platforms it so it was cool and what we
decided the takeaway from this is we got
to do viral clips all the time we gotta
we gotta be like obama the club isn't
the best place to find
whatever exactly it's not even a
conversation this is now just a
collection of clips
and the clip the clip had 60 000 views
too uh your twitter clip of you talking
about it
really yeah well the shitty part is that
it's
you talking about it and me looking at
just like it kept
showing my face and you're talking the
whole time and i'm just dude
that's the way the world goes you put
the white man's face up there and the
brown guy's just in the back
coming up with ideas and and handing
them over that's why
they get our voices confused because
they say i look like a pro but i talk
like a nerd and you look like a nerd but
talk like a bro
dude that was the most spot-on i wasn't
even i was like i'm not mad at all that
is
so accurate and um
you know i mixed now i understand why
people keep saying this thing that they
get as confused and victimized
now um let's talk about sex
um you have something on here and you
before we get into it i want to tell you
a fun fact so we have this list where
sean
and i list ideas he has one thing and it
says um
why aren't young people having sex and
what are the opportunities here
and apparently 31 of men 18 and 24 were
sexually inactive
before yes inactive um
and the tweet was from a guy named nat
allison
um who does a bunch of cool stuff the
tweet's not there anymore
for some reason um or at least i can't
see it get cancelled probably
can't say apparently you can't say man
anymore so this guy nat
is really interesting his name's nat
ellison uh
google he's got like a cool website he
owns uh this agency business
did you know that this guy so he's
interested in this because he owns this
thing called like
um i'll look at what's called but it's a
kegel app do you know what a kegel is
i do know what a kegel is it is okay the
like exercise you do
with your private parts yeah so
basically it
it makes it so you don't premature
ejaculate and
i think women do it too you know i don't
know like
i think women do it because it it like
it can increase like the pleasure
but also i think it's just healthy for
you to do like it's just like a
it's just like a movement that's good
for you i guess i don't know and
this guy his name is eliason nat eliason
he has
a an app called uh uh i i'll look it up
what it's called but it should be called
squeeze
because to do it to do a kegel you're
basically trying to like
you know for a guy you're basically
trying to like flex your balls that's
the best way i could describe it
um and and for a girl i'm sure there's
you know the equivalent
but i don't know what it is it's called
stamina
stamina i don't know what that play on
words is anyway
it walks you through how to do these
kegel exercises and it makes like 100k a
year
he just made it one time and it just
ranks
it's a crazy interesting thing kegel
exercises i never i never knew that was
a thing
uh go ahead um okay so so
we've talked about this before and
before when we said
uh i think you actually were the
original person to kind of rant about
this you were like
dude kids aren't having sex you're like
i went to this
you know people make funny for the hot
dog stand thing they're like we get it
you used to own a hot dog stand
the other story that i've heard you tell
a number of times because very
entertaining and i think it gets you
hyped up is
you went to some camp and they had a
bunch they had like a gen z
like you went to some summit and i had a
gen z analyst there
and the gen z analyst was like hey all
the kids are depressed and not having
sex
and you were like dude what's going on
and you talked about replica which was
this app
messaging app where you message like a
virtual girlfriend and
i tried it out you've tried it out um
after you told me about it i went
downloaded it
and it was okay it was interesting
there's definitely a bunch of people who
are really into this
it's like this ai virtual girlfriend but
i have a different
slant to it that i want to bring up here
so and by the way this whole sex thing
this has been a problem in japan i think
for years
right right yeah there's like a you know
the sexless generation or something they
call it like
um okay so i want to actually talk about
a company that's
based in austin right where you're where
right where you are you might be able to
see it if you look out the window
it's called interactive life forms llc
you know these guys
uh yeah i i know where their building is
i've seen their building
do you know what they make no
interactive do they make sex styles
interactive life forms this is the maker
of the fleshlight
and so i wanted to tell you about this i
did a little research i got a message
from a founder of a tech company
uh i won't say his name because he said
no uh he said don't say
his name but he messaged me and he goes
dude idea
modern fleshlights and i was like what
he goes fleshlights and he breaks
he broke it down for me he goes the um
the sex toy market is bigger than you
think
he goes uh female sex toys like a dildo
or a vibrator
are on the rise and there's this big
like kind of like
anti-stigma like people trying to remove
the stigma around it
uh i don't know if you've seen any of
this but it's like kind of the feminist
movement
um they call it they call it sex
positivity which is basically like hey
sex doesn't need to be taboo it doesn't
need to be stigma
um it's okay to have sex that doesn't
make you like you know a bad person or
something like that
and so there's this sex positivity
movement and with that has been this big
boom
in sales of sex toys primarily female
sex toys
so i started looking at the most popular
male sex toy which is
the fleshlight and so here's some
information about the fleshlight
uh it was started by this guy steve
shubin
and this guy's super interesting he
basically he's a si he's one of 13 kids
he uh go he plays college football then
he goes into the army then he comes back
and he's a police officer with the swat
team in
la and then he like retires from swat
when he's like 30 something because he's
like
i love being in the police force but um
it doesn't pay well so i'm gonna start a
business
and his wife is a pro tennis player so
this is
he's got this hot tennis player wife and
he's like i'm going to start a business
he doesn't know what he's going to start
and by the way do you know who that hot
wife and steve schuman's
son is no who aubrey marcus the founder
of on it
oh no way i didn't know yeah and he
joe rogan yes because flashlight was joe
rogan's first sponsor that aubry secured
that's amazing okay so i'll get into
that that's actually a part of this so
um so he so years go by he does nothing
then they're in their 40s
um steve's wife gets pregnant and the
doctor tells him hey you're in your 40s
so this is kind of like an at-risk
pregnancy
um so you can't uh you can't be having
sex
and he's like okay doc like you know
what do you want me to do i'm a six
three red-blooded american what what am
i supposed to do
and so um he starts thinking about it
and he goes
why isn't there a um why isn't there a
a sex toy for men and so he
originally plans to make a mannequin and
in fact in 1998 he gets a patent
for a mannequin with sexual application
so it's basically like a doll
that he wants to make so he's trying to
make this doll and he puts in 50k
and he starts working on this doll and
he's he's trying to blend all these
different polymers how do you get this
skin
feel of this doll how do you get the
flesh to feel like flesh how do you get
it to look like a doll feel like a doll
i feel like a human
and um and he makes it a family business
so he brings his sons into this to the
table
they get a white board out and they
start uh brainstorming together as a
family which i find
hilarious uh because you know in my
family this is not a
it's not a business we can start
together so he he keeps going
two years go by he's put into a quarter
million dollars now he's sold
zero uh zero to zero products so far
and he keeps trying to make this full
body doll
and he meets a guy one day a friend of
his and his friends like hey
um i think what you're doing is great
there's this weird taboo around this
but why not more pleasure in the world
what's the problem so he says
um will you give me one i'll buy one off
you and he says cool what's your address
i'll send you the doll and he's like no
dude no way i can't bring that doll into
my house he's like just take out the
part that's like the vagina of the doll
and send me that like put it in a little
box and my wife won't see it and
just send me that and so he's like dude
if my friend who wants this
won't like can't buy this doll this doll
is dead so that's why he pivoted from
the doll
to just the just the like you know just
the the organ part of it just a single
piece one component
and so he's like okay how do we brand
this so him and his sons are
brainstorming and they're like
what do guys like guys like tools okay
this thing's kind of like a flashlight
okay we'll call this the fleshlight so
that's how it gets its name
uh during that process and so here this
was like a father-son project
father-son project multiple weird man
and so
um now years have gone by they've put in
over two million dollars
and this guy believes so much in this
thing he ramps up production he's
pumping out
1200 units a day before they've sold
anything because he's like the world is
gonna love this they're gonna buy this
thing
and um so he goes all in on this to meet
this you know future demand
and turns out they actually did it so
the fleshlight now
these guys do i believe about 100
million dollars in revenue
it's definitely above 50. it's they
don't report it but it to me i did some
sleuthing and
i think it's 100 million a year company
over 100 employees
they um basically dominate the market
for
for male sex toys now and uh you know
this guy who went all in on this thing
it ended up being a successful family
business which i think is
you know just a heartwarming story what
a crazy story and i had heard a little
bit about it but i didn't realize
i didn't know all those details but by
the way this is the best part of the
whole story
so he he opens up a facility in austin
so he's manufactured near you
um then he has a one in spain and he has
one somewhere else in asia i think
and he has so much like like
manufacturing capacity
so what do they do with the excess
capacity when they when they have a
little extra
guess what they make they make
prosthetics
for elephants who have had their legs
blown off
in the you know from where there's mines
in in southeast asia
um so they're they're the top maker of
elephant prosthetics
in southeast asia that's their backup
that's their side business
what got you interested in this uh well
when this guy said it i was like
you know the founder who messaged me he
you know this is might have to bleep
this but he goes
dude every guy jacks off there's got to
be a market what if you he's like
what if she's like i don't own this
product you don't own this product he
goes but
what if this thing made it 10 times
better isn't that crazy that there's
still a taboo around this
that's going to change dude the sex
positivity thing for women it's going to
affect men
i bet you you can make a modern-day ddc
version of the fleshlight
and so i started thinking about it and
started looking up okay how big is this
how big is this industry
and it is a pretty big industry like
they do like the sex toy industry itself
is about 20 billion
dollars a year percentages to men
so women so this is kind of i was trying
to figure out the sales difference so
it's mo
it's dominated by female um sales so the
fleshlight is the biggest of males but
uh
the female industry is much much bigger
about 65 percent of women say that they
have used one
um there was a stat that said 50 of mail
men said that they've used one which
i don't believe um i don't i know a lot
of dudes i haven't heard one ever talk
about this so maybe it's just
happening on the download sex toy yeah
like i've never i've never had
one conversation with a friend not a
single yeah
so yeah so i don't know if i believe
that stat but
um basically the european market is
bigger than the american market
like places like italy it's like super
common apparently they're you know free
love
um places the fastest growing markets
right now are india and china
where it's the most taboo but what's
happened is because it's all gone to
e-commerce
and the e-commerce companies are using
very discreet packaging like they send
it to you and it looks like one thing
but inside is another and so that's the
like
that's where this thing is growing and
so there's a bunch of startups in this
space as well that are
um doing like 15 million a year like
love honey
like just just check out this traffic so
uh
the top the top website for this the top
sort of amazon for this thing is called
adam and eve
yeah i was just i was just looking at
adam and eve uh because they have stores
all over san francisco
they they have about eight million
visitors a month to their ecommerce
store which is a huge
e-commerce store uh lovehoney has about
four million to their store
and what's interesting is there's all
these problems all this friction and
trying to
build one of these companies because
stripe won't let you
take payments why wouldn't stripe let
you take payments for a deal they say
they say we don't um we do not do any
sexual products
so so you can use shopify but shopify
uses stripe
and so you can't do shopify basically
because stripe won't allow so
adam and eve love honey these these
companies they can't uh they can't
process on stripe
and so there's an opportunity i think
for for you know building stripe for
vice products because
cannabis can't use stripe and neither
can any uh
any any sex products uh porn can't use
stripe and so
if you know just those three industries
alone that's like multiple hundreds of
billions of dollars of turnover
and so who's building stripe for vice i
don't know i want to go i want to go
look into that
another one of these like opportunities
is um
is is that you can build a a brand that
figures out a new form of marketing
because you can't advertise on facebook
or instagram um or any like kind of
display network that's
uh mainstream for these products and so
i was looking into how do they get
around this and i was curious
how would you get around this if you
were trying to market one of these
products
it's an interesting sort of like job
interview question i would ask
somebody who wants i would write
articles on like
you write articles that are yeah so you
have to write let me
all right so if we're talking about like
a vibrator you would write an article
about like
uh sexual health i guess or i don't know
whatever
i mean i would have to i would have to
do research what what
a woman who is about to buy this what is
she what type of content
interests her right and i would write
that article and i would display it on
outbrain or i would display it on
uh i don't know where would i display it
it's hard
so i i looked into how these guys are
doing it and i think there's there's
three interesting pornhub you got to go
you could do like pornhub so so they use
the adult
ad networks like traffic junkie and exo
click so they advertise on porn sites
basically that's that's a good that's
the easy one
pretty straightforward um the other
thing that they do is they
they do heavy like content so so even
though you can't advertise
on um on facebook and you can you're
kind of limited on google you can do it
for certain keywords
and for just stuff that people searching
for so people are searching for what is
the best
one i should buy what you know reviews
and so
you remember how the cat the the
mattress company casper was buying up
the mattress review websites
um and then like promoting casper so
that's what these guys will do as well
they'll buy up the review sites
and then they'll just put their products
as the best reviewed product on there
and they'll say this is you know i'm an
affiliate for this for this company
um so that's one way and then the i
thought the most innovative one
and they also do like kind of direct so
like you were saying uh fleshlight was
one of the first sponsors on joe rogan
they'll do that they'll go
direct to podcasts or newsletters that
are willing to take them as a sponsor
and they'll they'll go for it there but
um the last one i thought was
interesting was
what fleshlight did this is a little bit
this whole segment's a little bit
x-rated
you know um you know apologies if you're
listening to this with kids in the car
you know i hope you've skipped forward
at this point but basically what
fleshlight did was
they wanted celebrity sponsors um so
what they did was
you know nike goes to lebron james and
says okay we want you to sponsor our
stuff
um so are they gonna get women to be the
they got they went to
famous models and porn stars and they
created
molds of them and so it's like you can
buy
the i forgot the i looked up this chart
of who was the top selling
skew of that and so there's a woman
kayla or shayla or something like that i
don't remember her name was but
she's some model she some points are i
don't know who she is but she's famous
and they they they bring them in they do
a cast a cast
mold of her body and then they turn that
into a product and then she can sell
that product to her fans
and so i was thinking if you were going
to do this now you have only fans where
where
you know i think a billion billion plus
dollars is being paid out to their
creators
i would go to only fans uh creators and
i would do this
i would do that model for them i think
that would be probably the strongest
distribution tactic you could get
dude what a fascinating thing i uh
would you ever i would invest in this
but i wouldn't i would never work on
this
i would never work on this i have zero
interest in this from
from you know like to actually like
pursue it but
i do think it's one of those things that
nobody talks about and so because nobody
talks about it
it's both interesting and it's
surprising when you look into it how
this whole system actually works so i
like
you know just like i love the silk road
but i would never go on the silk road
and buy drugs but i like to learn about
it and see how it worked and how big it
was and
who was behind it and how they kept it
stealthy
like that's fascinating to me just like
i like watching prison shows
but i'm not trying to go murder anybody
i like watching you know bank heist but
i'm not planning to rob anybody that's
how i am with this
these types of products so at the adam
and eve store or
what was it called uh yeah adam and eve
stores um
i saw those we had so many locations in
san francisco we probably had three or
four or five different locations
um it's a pretty huge business hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue
currently owned by
i believe a private equity company um
that is also another fascinating
business did you research that
uh no i didn't research that one but
what other
two other like interesting things about
how they how they market these things i
thought was pretty clever
uh it just shows you know
entrepreneurial creativity here all
right so uh there's one company that's
doing these like uh you know like the
the sort of mlm model
which which is uh you get one person
who's kind of a seller for you
and they have a party so this is like
the old tupperware parties
um they call them passion parties for
this and so they have women invite their
friends over and they're called passion
parties where they show the different
toys and
what they could do or whatever i don't
know how this sounds like the most
awkward party to me but apparently it's
working
um the second one that i thought was
super interesting was
um they basically there was a company
called
diamond products and they make they make
uh some brand of something i have no
idea
and they couldn't advertise in any
traditional channel so they went and
they bought
um sir richard's condoms company so they
said oh
condoms are allowed to be advertised on
tv and on
on different websites it's more loose to
like trojan right we've all seen trojan
ads on tv for example
so if the restrictions are loose or
there they went and bought that company
and then on their website they just they
upsell other products basically
and so he went and bought this company
because he goes they're sold in whole
foods
he's like this makes it so easy for me
to advertise because now i own this
little thing
he's like it's my trojan horse hahaha
like you know this is how i advertise
my sex products company and so i thought
that was pretty interesting and
you know i think if you did this with
instagram models and oldie fans
you could basically just copy the um
what's that watch brand
mvmt you can copy the the movement
movement watches brand
uh model and try to you know they they
went to 100 million in sales and watches
i bet you could do the same
uh using their influencer strategy dude
how interesting like i
i i love learning from these types of
people i i don't even like
i'm i don't even like going to this i
went to the fleshlight website i don't
even like going to that i think right
close the tab yeah i think it's weird
i'm on my work computer just so anyone
uh at hubspot listens yeah i apologize
my uh my wife's dad
listens to the podcast i i'm just going
to tell him hey don't listen to this one
i apologize if you like well it was a
fairly
academic discussion about something well
the worst part is now my
now i'm getting retargeted like crazy
because i was doing research on this for
the pod
and now all my ads are completely uh
messed up
well do you want to talk about another
interesting person
yes or do you want to talk about an idea
personally
okay we're gonna do a an interesting
person okay
there's this guy who we're gonna do
billy the week here where this guy and i
by the way i think we're gonna do this
we've discussed doing this every friday
maybe we will but google by the way
we need like a jingle for the billy of
the week it needs to be like
you know the billy of the week somebody
make us a little jingle for that
that would be pretty cool um we do need
that google brad kelly and make sure you
spell it like
b-r-a-d so brad space k-e-l-l-e-y
okay if you're on your phone do it brad
kelly now you're gonna see a picture of
a guy with a red beard
you see the red beard i see okay and
then two over you're gonna see
a picture of an old guy with a longer
like he looks like uh
like mark twain yep see it black okay so
that's the same guy the photos are just
he's just older now so
this guy he's so interesting to me for a
couple different reasons so
this guy's name is brad kelly he at this
point he's probably in his 60s
and he's known as the man with a million
acres that was a
headline that was written in the new
york times about him and
they wrote it about him because he is
one of the largest landowners in america
at one point he was number three or
number four and he's kind of known for
being incredibly
reclusive so he doesn't do any
interviews he doesn't do anything like
that
but he's bad to the bone he's a really
interesting guy
and i read a little bit about him and
i've kind of got a feel for this guy and
he's so intriguing to me so he was born
uh you know he's 65 years older-ish he
was born in kentucky
uh went to college in kentucky but at
age 19 dropped out because he started
buying warehouses and he started making
enough money buying and leasing out
warehouses that he goes all right i'm
going to do this
i don't need school anymore and
eventually he started renting them out
to people who were
building stuff so creating little
miniature factories
he would fix them up and lease them to
people and eventually he saw that people
were using them to store
tobacco and one of his tendons moved out
and he got whole he they left a machine
that turned
tobacco and like pumped them into
cigarettes or you know like a like a
rolling machine or something like that
and he was like well i got this machine
let's try it and so he started making
cheap cigarettes
and eventually he rolled uh he made it a
proper company and he called it
commonwealth brands
and if you google commonwealth brands i
don't smoke cigarettes but i recognized
some of the brands they're like uh i
think he has like
15 or so cigarette brands yeah it's like
i think parliament's that's like
uh when i was a kid that would like we
would joke like if someone spoke
parliament that means they were like a
broke kid um
uh but he made cheap cigarettes and
after 10 years he sold this cigarette
company for a billion dollars
and i hate smoking and i don't think
it's cool to smoke
um and he doesn't either and he but he
didn't hide that he goes i've never
defended smoking
and i hope that it will be phased out of
society but i did it because you know it
made i made a living doing it
you know it made me a living for me and
using almost all i love when
billionaires say
they're just trying to make a living
it's like no you made you made like a
billion livings
that's a lot you made a lot of livings
and with all this money he did a couple
interesting things
the first thing that he did well he
didn't do it first but the first
interesting thing is he bought lonely
planet you know what lonely planet is
i've heard that name what is that is
that a dating site that's a date i bet
you if you look at your
uh your book collection you might have a
lonely planet book it's a travel website
and book company
oh okay and it was a big it was a really
big deal for many years and then when
digital came along it got crushed
and he bought lonely planet for 70
million dollars
and he had us and they probably had 300
employees and he had a kid that he liked
somehow met this young guy who was 24
and he put him as ceo
and they never signed a contract they
just shook hands and they go all right
you're a ceo now
you know talk to me if you need me such
a kentucky thing to do
just shake your hand and this kid ran it
and it didn't do so hot i mean it
on like it would have been cool if
there's a better ending to that part of
the story
right either to a combination of the 24
year old sucking and covid they sold it
uh
for like 50 million so he didn't make
money on it um
but what he did with the rest of his
money is he bought
ranches and leased them back to the
owners and
they make a little bit of profit but not
a significant amount of profit and at
this point
he owns um over a million acres in
america
which is a huge huge huge amount making
him and 2012 the fourth largest land
owner in america
the guy never does interviews he you
can't find him if you want to he's
really hard to find
uh the only reason people really truly
know about him is at one point he sold
one of his ranchers for 400 million
dollars
uh really interesting guy i like him
because
he's uh i think that like i get
caught in this world on twitter of like
oh building
build in public you know what's your mrr
i gotta go to executive coaching
and it's so nice to hear from a guy this
guy actually
seems like a pretty thoughtful guy but
he definitely gives off the redneck vibe
uh obviously he's highly intelligent but
they say that like he goes to his
ranches and he likes to drink bourbon's
bourbon and wear a kilt
he's like kind of a wild guy he's into
some weird [__] all right
yeah but pretty interesting guy and i
wanted to bring this guy up because i
bet most people
have never heard of him uh but so
interesting he also owns
do you know what kentucky downs is the
horse horse track
yeah he owns that oh wow and so he just
owns
all types of real estate and that's what
he put all of his money into
very interesting person uh yeah this is
this is cool
so why were you saying the part about
people um
who have like executive coaches and well
what was the contrast there so
to explain that one like i see people
who've got like small ass companies who
like are
not even they're like barely just
started and they're like
tweeting out like leadership quotes or
they're talking about like
uh how they need to be more inclusive at
their company or this and that
and i just get sick of this hype thing
and i see all the people like oh build
in public
uh and and i'm guilty of all this as
well um but like all the and we're part
of the hype cycle right we're media
but it's cool to see someone who you've
never heard of who just
is anonymous and shuts the [__] up and
just works and does cool stuff and has a
cool life
and it's entirely like you know
everyone's like i got in a fight on
twitter about people
which uh about buying domain names you
think this guy knows how to buy a domain
name
in one of the interviews he said he he
doesn't know how to use email
right yeah this guy's not vegan yeah
no this guy eats vegans right
this guy is made of leather uh yeah okay
so you just like that he's like kind of
like a tough guy
rough guy business guy doesn't give a
[__] and uh
everybody else you know makes such a big
deal of little things it's kind of weird
i just think it's cool to see
to hear different perspectives and i'm
sure that uh he does a lot of bad stuff
i mean he owns a cigarette company right
like that's kind of
pretty shitty but uh it was just cool
it's cool to have a different
perspective and this guy if you google
them
i'm pretty sure there's only three
pictures that i've
i've researched this guy a lot i i've
only found three pictures of him
and he's worth three or four billion
dollars i like it all right he is indeed
the billy of the week um i wonder i
wonder
who i wonder how people will will react
to this guy because i think some people
are like so anti-cigarettes that they're
like
you are you know you that you're saying
that you
you're kind of idolizing this guy who is
a uh you know who did bad things like
you know like a warlord almost and so i
don't know
you were the one who also said you would
not invest in jewel right was that you
yeah look i'm not i'm not defending this
person's actions i think but i think
that no matter how evil or horrible
someone is
there's you can always find something
interesting maybe saying
admirable is a bit of a stretch but you
can always find something interesting no
matter how bad someone is and i don't
think this guy is necessarily a bad guy
but yeah he i mean
he [__] he's still poison yeah it's
pretty right
see i think of it i think i don't know
maybe i'm a little disconnected from
reality but for me i'm like
i don't like movies where everybody is a
good guy i would not play a game
a video game where you just walk around
as a good samaritan like those aren't
fun to me
and i think that the real world has all
kinds of people
shapes colors beliefs all kinds of
different things
and i'm interested in
the variety of ways that people live
their life and i'm glad that people live
their life doing all these different
things
even though a lot of them are like
villains or a lot of them i'm not saying
this guy's a villain but like
i think that's just the way the world is
and i think it's crazy to believe that
the world shouldn't be that way or won't
be that way where people are going to
live their life doing different things
maybe this guy likes to drink bourbon
and wear kilts on a farm that he owns
like all right great i'm glad that
character exists
i'm glad that that that you know i'm
glad these characters exist i think that
um most people will not feel that way
most people will say well
if this person's a bad guy um you know
he shouldn't exist and i don't know i
i find that to be this is not the way i
think about it i believe
every great man or every great woman is
also a bad man
so what i mean by that is if you are at
all
if you're considered great at anything
or one of the best
inevitably you have many enemies because
you can't make everyone happy
right now by the way can you tweet that
out so i'm doing this thing i'm getting
uh behind me
one of the things that's going to go
behind me is i'm pre i'm getting these
laser etched
signs that are tweets basically it's
called lasertweets.com
and so uh you can basically get any
tweet
turned into a wooden laser etched sign
and i'm gonna put i'm gonna hang a
couple of my favorite quotes and tweets
behind me
and one of them one of my favorites is
every great man is also a bad man
and so i need you to tweet that out so
that i can do it but what you can't do
is you can't or you could do person
um if you want to not make it gender
specific here
but i need you to tweet that out so i
can i can get that one made yeah you're
gonna get you're gonna get on my wall
i don't think i may i think i made up
that phrasing but
uh i read it in a book and uh i don't
remember exactly how they phrased it but
that's how i phrased it but i believe it
to be true and dude i did so much
research on this guy
that i went and i went to land forums so
a really interesting research tactic
that you should do
is you type in whatever you're searching
for like flashlight and then you type in
forum
right and then you are brought to user
generated content of message boards
and what people are saying or you could
do the same thing but you just type in
the word reddit
it's pretty sick and i went to land
forums where this guy bought people's
land
and they go yeah you know or someone's
like hey this guy named
brad kelly offered to buy my land who
sold to him
and people were like yeah we sold to him
uh he's fine enough
doesn't bother us and offered us a fair
deal and so
they're like well and we all and people
said well and we read about him doing
cigarettes and that kind of sucks but
he's never caused us a problem so anyway
every great man is also a bad man
i like it uh did you want to do any any
of these other ones or are we saving
them
uh i think this one should they should
be saved
okay i have one quick one because i
don't really have much to say but we
talked we could do the ndvc one
okay i'm gonna do a one quick plug for
these guys that took an idea we talked
about and they made it
so we talked about levels.fyi which is a
salary comparison website we had a whole
episode about like
open salaries and should you or should
you not transparent data how that helps
blah blah blah and we said hey levels
does this for the tech industry where
you can go see all right if i'm a
facebook
product manager level five what will i
make if i live in seattle what will i
make if i live in san francisco what's
the benchmark what are the
what is some data so i know if i'm
getting if i'm getting hosed if they
gave me a fair job offer or not fair job
offer
and so we said dude somebody should do
this for other industries
because this is awesome um why isn't
this happening another so these guys
made
med levels.fyi and it's basically dr pay
um and so they if you go to it you can
see they don't have a ton of data yet
but um they're getting some they're
getting doctors to to
put in how much they're getting paid
based on where they live what type of
doctor they are
i think it's great super simple it's
just basically an air table
displayed on a website so really easy to
build and uh
no it's uh google forms i think yeah i'm
saying like in
theory right it's like such a simple
simple product to do so med levels.fyi
good good job by those guys
if you're a doctor listen go put your
[__] in there yeah it's pretty cool
i was looking at this um all right we'll
wrap it up by talking about one more
thing and maybe we should put this in
the beginning
but let me ask you how has your angel
investing gone so far i'll tell you in
10 years that's the problem with angel
investing
[Laughter]
but how many deals have you invested in
uh
i think a little under 20 maybe like 18
something like that 18 companies we've
invested in
deployed about i don't know million and
a half 2 million or something like that
and do you feel confident that you have
some winners
uh yeah definitely there's some winners
um
now we'll see i think any anything
anything can happen but i would say i'd
be surprised if out of these 18
if we don't have you know two companies
that are worth
a billion dollars or more i'd be
surprised so
wow that's pretty sick so we um a few
weeks ago
i tweeted out something that andrew chen
said basically i asked andrew chen who's
a partner at
andreessen horowitz what his advice to
me for angel investing was and he told
me his opinion and i tweeted that out
people [__] on me even though i was like
i'm not saying this i'm just
or i'm just like i'm the messenger yeah
like i'm just like reporting on
someone interesting opinion but i did
tend to agree
on a couple of the things and one of
them was that
there's this narrative that you there's
this narrative of people who
hate vc and they're like i would rather
grow slower and it's like okay that's
cool do that
but in order and they also say
profits matter you know like and they
love to mock silicon valley companies
they're like dude these guys you know
they don't know anything about profits
sorry i'm just over here running a
profitable business
just growing steady every year and so
they they like to get on that kind of
high horse which is crazy because like
both can exist and be wonderful
but there was this guy who i really like
and i don't mean to [__] on him at all
um his it was called ndvc and it was
it was kind of weird i don't know why it
was a venture capital firm because
its whole shtick was basically we invest
in bootstrap
businesses that want to grow slowly um
they didn't exactly say
slowly but it was for bootstrapped
companies which is
again a little bit of an oxymoron why is
the bootstrap company gonna be taking
venture capital
right but a lot of people really liked
it and the guy who ran it i forget his
name
i met with him awesome guy and they went
out of business
this week and i think it's his name
bryce i like bryce bryce is a good guy
but the model didn't work and i wanted
to bring this up
because something that andrew said was
he said two things he was said
uh invest in quantity so just kind of
throw money at a bunch of stuff so like
anything that seems promising just
kind of mindlessly invest in it and
second
make sure it's growing 3x a year if it's
not then it's not good and a lot of
people didn't like when i said that
and they didn't like it i think because
it kind of hurt their feelings of like
well
you're saying i'm not worthy of venture
capital and the answer is is
yeah you're not right you're not and but
that's okay that doesn't like you
shouldn't be offended
um right you don't have to shut down
your business it just means
this type of asset this type of venture
you know venture
capital is chasing a certain profile a
company and you may not fit that profile
and by the way i think that most people
i bet you
i mean this sounds so douchey i bet you
i've made significantly more money than
a lot of people who have raised
absolutely and so i was telling somebody
this the other day i was like
um i was like you know media companies
we're talking about media companies
and you know you guys just sold you you
guys are media company
and it wasn't the biggest exit ever it's
not like you know some insane thing
but i was like dude he i don't how much
did you raise total like a million and a
half dollars two million dollars
something like that
a million a million dollars right so it
took so little money
and then not so so give give the profile
it was a million dollars and it took you
how many years from start to
finish uh finished but but one week
start as in we raised money to finish uh
less than five years
and i made eight eight figures right
exactly and so and you owned you know
majority of the business or whatever so
like
because you didn't have to raise all
this money and dilute yourself over and
over and over again from round after
round after round
and it's like there are if you look at
companies that are selling for a billion
dollars where the founder owns four
percent
or two percent or seven percent and um
you know it's not like and they
and they sweated it for 10 years and
every hair on their head is gray
because uh because of that path so it
doesn't the size of the exit is not
not linked really to the to the uh
outcome for the for the founder
themselves
i agree which proves that we're not or i
i know
for speaking for myself and i i think
you you're not [__] on this
this idea of anti-vc whatever but
this company went out of business and it
goes against this narrative of like
if you're gonna give money to venture
capital
or companies that fit the profile of vc
you want them to
be what many would just think or
describe as reckless
right and one thing i didn't get
why did they go out of business so so
basically they couldn't raise more money
was the idea
yeah right that's how a vc fund goes out
of business and he said in his thing
he's like we invested in 10 companies
or whatever he gave some numbers so so
tell me he goes they were all
bootstrapped and profitable and they're
all still going and they're
40 you know he said something like we've
invested these they're all still going
they're all still profitable
but we couldn't raise any more money
it's like what what do you i don't
understand what what is his reason why
did they go out of business
he kind of sounded like he was crying a
little bit like he was kind of whining
because he's like
our lps didn't like our model so they
pulled
the plug because you know whatever i
did i didn't read the thing very
carefully so you tell me you you looked
into this no i mean
yeah why is he saying they failed i
don't think he was whining i think he
was just saying the fact that like most
people
don't like this idea and weren't willing
to stick it out and i don't blame them
because if you go to indy.bc the website
it's a video of a
unicorn head on fire as if like they're
anti-unicorn and i might have
returns are good if his returns are good
every
people would still be looking to back
the fund because people who invest in
the returns aren't as good as other
stuff like so that's what he needs to
say it's not that people don't like this
he needs to say
i was wrong my returns weren't as good
as i thought they would be and they were
not good enough to get more money
because people invested i invest in vc
funds i also would invest in real estate
which has a different profile
i'll invest in crypto which has a
different risk return profile
i invest in many things and so that's
why i thought it was kind of whining
because i didn't
it didn't just say the honest truth i
had this idea that this would be a great
way to invest
and my but my returns were actually
shitty and therefore
i couldn't raise more money and either
that's true or
his returns were actually good and he
sucked at going and getting new
investors i didn't
there's only two ways to go about it
right like i didn't understand
i didn't i stopped reading because i
didn't he wasn't saying the truth in my
opinion
no i mean he said the truth he said that
uh like our strategy
a lot of lps bailed uh it cost us 80 of
our lp base they didn't want to come
back
um and it was just yeah the strategy
didn't didn't work in the sense of
investors did he post his returns no
okay that's the thing he needed to say
right he's saying they didn't like
our strategy it was so he was kind of
just like patting himself on the back i
felt
he's like they didn't like that we were
going against the grain going against
the vc thing and they had to pull out
because of that
it's like well is it that they didn't
like what you were doing or is it that
it wasn't working and the returns
weren't very good and they didn't
believe the returns were going to be
very good
i don't know i i'm being harshly i don't
know the guy but
no he's cool and i'm not bringing this
up to show them i think it's cool he
took a shot
it was a bad shot though and that's
that's great right you take swings
sometimes you miss for sure
but uh i think though it's important
it's important that we look at
what this what's what does this mean
here and i think that someone like
andrew chen who's this
from the outside you think of him as
like an elitist like
went to uh i don't know he just like
give this vibe that he's like
an elitist type of guy um but
and so and he kind of represents a lot
of people like him right these like
vcs who like oh like [__] these tech
bros and
the reality is though is that that
strategy of like
doing stuff that appears to be reckless
from the outside
it is the right strategy it just feels
really uncomfortable for a lot of people
dude if you if you it's it's a classic
don't hate the player hate the game
it's not that it's not that vc's decided
oh you know what i'll do
i'm going to invest in a bunch of
companies and one or two will return the
fund and everything else will go to zero
it's not that they
want that right that's actually
extremely stressful for them
um that hey if i get into this company
that becomes a 10 billion
plus company i'm a hero and i'm the best
and if i just miss them
and i invest in a bunch of other good
companies that didn't quite get there i
suck and i can't raise my next fund and
i'm out of a job
and um and so so it's crazy to me that
like
they're not picking this that just is
the nature of the game and they have to
play it
if they want to succeed at it it's like
in any game theory
um the game will the players in the game
will eventually find
the meta game the strategy that is the
optimal strategy
and if you just because of your like you
know
your opinion and your personality and
your morals don't want to play it cool
that's fine but you're just not going to
get
you're not going to be playing the
optimal strategy you're going to
eventually lose the game
and so i think it's crazy that people
hate the vcs when it's just that's the
way that innovation works
the innovations that break through
become humongous
and the innovations that don't become
zeros and uh or close to zeros
and the winners are so big that that's
they dominate all the returns but then
there's this other ground where it's
like
fvc which me personally i'm on that boat
where i want to be a vc but i don't want
to take
vc money and that that's this other
group of people it's like dude they all
can exist
like right and that's what that quote is
so insightful right don't hate the
player hit the game cool you can hate
the game that's allowed
that's in the quote um you're allowed to
hate the game and say i'm going to play
a different game
no problem you can play games where you
bootstrap or you don't raise vc money
where you
you don't do business at all you go be
an employee somewhere no problem
that's always an option well
i guess we just did a little rant but i
wanted to bring that up um
we'll see if this episode turns out to
be anything interesting
um i'll bring you how we do b plus
i want the graphics guys to like slam a
big b plus all over the screen
all right why b plus you got to give
give the people that your explanation
why
why why are you saying what you're
saying i mean i it was good research but
it just wasn't as juicy as it could be
it was good
i've never seen sean more animated than
when he talks about flashlights by the
way
yeah i was super into that to be honest
i i got ruined when i went to the
website it's pretty
freaking disgusting but
did you go to the website no i did all
my research i didn't go to their website
it's not great it's pretty gross
um but no i think it's interesting i
think what we'll have to do is um
i think uh like if we did an entire
episode on fleshlight or
entire episode on this guy brad kelly i
think it would be crazy fascinating
um i want more i thought i thought
you're saying i went too much into it
no that the flesh that was the best part
i'm just saying you're very animated
about it
yeah and i i have i have space but it's
cold so i have to talk in an animated
way to like not freeze
you're passionate about flashlights it's
okay so i've been listening i listen to
a true crime podcast every night which
is weird that i'm in bed like with my
wife about to go to sleep
hearing about like how this guy just
like murdered and raped these people um
but it's this one lately called
generation y
it's really popular and all it is is two
guys discussing crimes and mysteries
ranging from 911
to serial murders to the bermuda
triangle
all that all that type of thing and all
they're doing is talking and retelling a
story
we should definitely just do that with
one interesting person
yeah i think that's great um although if
it's not true crime i don't know how
interesting people how interested people
would be
in it um if you told
a 60 to 70 to 90 minutes story in the
same way
that you told that fleshlight story um
people would love it
i could tell because i could i was
enthralled by it
what's the first story we could tell how
could we try it
well um one time we talked about this
the french bill gates that that guy was
so intriguing to me
um uh to do 60 minutes that's like you
can really only tell like your own story
or like
some something you really go or like a
you know the american kingpin store you
can like retell it retell the book
basically as
a podcast well that's what you're doing
at the end of the day which is you're
just reading
15 articles and you're telling the long
story about it
and what you could do is uh one of us
is the more more researched and the
other one listens and
asks questions okay all right i'm down
to try it if you have an idea am i wrong
abrayu
i mean it could work i'm just i don't
know how you can make it that exciting
like true crime
there's suspense there's mystery you
know what's gonna happen
i don't i guess business maybe like big
business scandals you could do that with
no dude you do it exactly like you did
the flesh the origin stories
yeah i think origin stories are good
right that's what i tried to do with the
fleshlight guy was like
basically you tell how this thing came
to be um
so i think you could do it that way it
works i don't i
but i agree with john i don't know how
you get 60 to 90 minutes out of it
i think you basically yeah forget the 69
minutes that doesn't matter it could be
20 minutes
it's no issue but um it's like just a
well-told story a well-researched and
therefore well-told
story about something that happened i
honestly know like for me i started
listening to this youtube channel that
basically is like it's like book
summaries
but um actually done good i actually
like it
and what's it called it's a productivity
game
as a youtube it's a youtube channel with
about half a million i think subscribers
or something like that
um i could be wrong on that but there's
a lot of subscribers um
but i've listened to probably 10 of
their book summaries of just books i've
had i bought
i just haven't got to i'm like do i
really want to go read like made to
stick
or can i just like watch this seven
minute video and like oh those are the
four principles i made to stick cool
i still might read the book but now i
know if it's like interesting or not
and so similarly i'm reading like you
know whether it's
um like for example i read this book uh
paypal
whatever the paypal origin story or
whatever if we just retold that
it's like you know just take the book
and then turn it into a 20-minute
retelling
of the story um i think that's pretty
that could be pretty well i know that
would work american kingpin would be
great
there's this awesome podcast called we
study billionaires which sounds lame but
honestly it's like you guys know it's
they're huge and it's really good
um and they'll read a book on someone or
just a long article and just retell the
story
right it's really good i love this
podcast it's called the investors
podcast
you've never heard of this yeah either
good man i know they're i know their
thumbnail the red thumbnail
they're huge yeah 40 million downloads
they have
so that would work off of fanboys um
i guess we're we should publish us
talking right now but speaking of books
you know what i'm doing is
this isn't what i'm doing with it i'm
just going to read one book this year
but i'm going to study the [__] out of
it
i'm sick of reading like two books a
month and not remembering anything
yeah i'm just for me like youtube is
just so much better like i'm just going
deep on like
you know like uh charlie munger peter
lynch youtube stuff and i'm just like
watching watching so many of their
videos or listening to their videos and
uh
there's just a lot of wisdom in there
and charlie munger said this thing he's
like
he's like i don't want to read the news
he goes i want to read something that
it made sense 30 years ago it makes
sense today it's going to make sense 30
years from now
and i'd rather just read that 10 times
than read like whatever the latest thing
is and that's kind of what you're saying
yeah i i agree um all right well um
let's bounce i'm gonna get my [__] set
up uh by the next podcast better
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what
never looking back
[Music]
um